[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice open phones here at triple eight
eight two five five two two five my
co-host today christy wright number one
best-selling author of the book business
boutique ramsay personality and host of
the christy wright podcast and um
lots of stuff to talk about today
christy just did a talk at the summit
the entree leadership summit in dallas
that we had a couple of weeks ago and it
was one of the most highly rated talks
among all the speakers that spoke that
week and there were
world-renowned communicators on that
stage she was uh
up against some tough competition to get
to get one of the top ratings for sure
my spot there earned my for sure but the
uh the reason the reason for the ratings
was not only the great delivery and your
speaking style and ability but the
content she was talking about balance
and i get to call
life balance matter of fact i spoke to a
company yesterday local company just a
friend of mine i ran by there and just
did a you know one of their talks for
them yep
and i did a little bit of q and a after
and
one of the young guys were saying hey i
got babies and i knew little babies and
i just started a business
how do i balance i mean it's a question
you and i have gotten for a couple
decades yes how do you balance how do
you bounce people call in here going
okay i want to get out of debt
and i know gazelle intensity means work
like no one else i mean i know there's a
great place to go when you're broke to
work i know i know all of that but but
i've got the kids and i'd like for them
to actually know that they have a father
or a mother and how do i balance how do
i balance how do i balance how do i
balance
and you know we teach people to be
intentional with their money
and the essence of what you told this
group of leaders that was so popular was
to be intentional with your time yeah
yeah well i think there's such a direct
correlation between time is money time
and money and it's not just the obvious
of you work and you make money but i
think when you start to realize that
time is one of our finite resources our
most finite resource even more finite
than money you can go get more money you
can't get more time then it gives you a
little bit of a fire under you to want
to steward it well be intentional with
it and and to your point dave when we
get asked this question we're always
asked in the same way balance is always
used as a verb how do i balance it all
how do i balance everything like we've
got juggling balls spinning plates
walking a tightrope it's always these
analogies that feel very stressful and
full of anxiety and so as i dug into
researching this more and more over the
past you know six to ten years i started
asking a different question
what if balance is not so much something
you do
as it is something you create in your
life a sense of of
peace and and confidence in the way that
you spend your time
and it leads you to a different answer
when you think about balance as
something you feel and create than just
something you do it gives you permission
to be gazelle intense when you're paying
off your debt because that's the right
thing at that time
and to put your phone away when you're
on vacation and focus on your kids
because that's the right thing at that
right at the right time and so um it's
amazing how it really did hit a nerve
and i think it's because our our world
is crazy busy and we've got you know a
phone in our pocket screaming our name
24 7. so we've got to have some
strategies to create a sense of balance
even when we live in a world that's very
out of balance
if you don't take a step back and take a
big gulp of air
there is never enough money
and there's never enough time that's
right
and the only way that there's a sense of
contentment with either one of those
subjects and they're they're
interrelated that way because jesus said
your treasure is where your heart is so
how you spend your time how you spend
your money
it says what's important to you yeah and
you always say that i can tell by
looking at your bank account and your
calendar what you care about because
that's where you spend your time and
that's where you spend your money and i
would say a lot of people experience
tension and stress and frustration
because they don't because they spend
their time and money on things that that
are not important to them and they feel
this frustration and so i love to help
people bridge that gap you know spending
their time on whatever since what you've
been saying with balance is what we've
been saying with budget
and it's like when you tell your money
what to do
on paper on purpose before the month
begins you'll do a budget and and you're
making the money to go where you want it
to go you feel like you got a raise yes
when you tell your time what to do
you're gonna find margin yes and you're
going to feel more you're going to say
i'm not doing that right and you're
going to feel more in control because
guess what you are
you are in control of your time and your
schedule and your calendar you set it
just like you set the budget you get to
make it look like what you want to but a
lot of people are passive and reactive
similar to their money and so i love to
help them like you help people with the
budget i love to help people take
control of their time to actually spend
their time on what matters most to them
then what's really cool is you can still
be crazy busy but you feel that sense of
balance because you're no longer trying
to do everything you're doing the right
things and that's where that feeling
comes from yeah
and and you're you're present
wherever you are i mean that's one of
your principles is to be where you is
yeah and you know we we talk about
social media and we talk about all the
distractions but what's interesting is
i i discovered a study and these are by
two harvard psychologists that cited
that the more present you are whether
that's not looking at your phone or not
even allowing your thoughts to wander to
all the things you've got to do when you
can truly be where your feet are
research shows you are happier overall
regardless of what you're doing it
doesn't matter if you're doing something
that's not as fun when you're present in
the moment it leads to more happiness
and so i love to help people figure out
what that looks like in their life and
put in habits because even if you create
the most perfect schedule in the world
if you're not present for it you miss it
so you have to figure out how to be
present so you can actually experience
your life
yeah so the morning run i did a three
mile run this morning
it's a really good idea to just enjoy
the run yeah
and not be thinking about the day and
thinking about which i did all morning
while i was running i did i did it
exactly wrong
all i did was think about i'm just going
i'm going to fix that today and that's
right out there and that guy i'm going
to get that
all through your brain you have your
best ideas on a run right yeah but
they're
you know you can't and it was you know
it was a beautiful tennessee morning
yeah and and you know i look back in a
sense i'm shouting myself but i think
what we all do is by not being there
i missed it because i was already here
we do that we do that dave you know this
is a silly example but last year when
matt and i went on vacation to fort
lauderdale we just had a little getaway
for a weekend
uh the weather forecast was really bad
it was a it was a bad forecast it was
gonna rain and thunderstorm and i'm just
like obsessed about us having a good
weekend and i'm still we're driving down
the main boulevard on the beach in
florida you're a weather girl
not as bad as rachel not near as bad as
rachel nobody's as bad as right no
rachel should have been a meteorologist
but i want but i wanted beach days i
want good weather we're driving down the
street
by the beach right there in fort
lauderdale and the top is down on the
convertible the weather is fine i'm
looking at the app on my phone and i am
just obsessively looking at the hourly
and the daily forecast and i felt god
say
look up
look at the weather right in front of
you it's fine yeah you're obsessing
about what's coming look at what's going
on right now and i thought gosh don't we
all do that i have to tell all three
girls in our family very regularly that
a 40 chance of rain means a 60 chance of
sunshine
geez man the glass is half full come on
oh yeah okay so if you want to know more
about this christy's got a tool to help
you
uh take the challenge to get 24 hours
added to your week
we're going to show you how to do it
and it goes with the money piece
text time finder to 33
444
text time finder to 33444
and we'll send you a free tool that
chrissy says is going to add 24 hours to
your week
it's kind of like getting a raise when
you do a budget
same thing when you start doing stuff on
purpose you immediately carve out the
superfluous garbage out of your life
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
still on baby step number one how'd you
guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
christy wright ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today this is the ramsey show where we
talk about your life your money and your
life
we're talking a little bit about life
balance coming out of that
segment and any of you have any
questions about that subject you can
jump in here on the air as well kelly
will put you on the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five uh gabriel is with us in los
angeles hi gabriel how are you
hi christy hi dave how you guys doing
great man what's up
hey so i have a question for you dave um
so i have i'm on baby step 2 right now
i have about 12 000 in my savings
and
right now at the moment i know i gotta
pay off all my debt and i have two car
payments
one of one of the cars
doesn't work though the engine went out
so it's going to cost me thousands of
dollars to fix it so my question is i
know i heard you i might have been a
couple weeks back saying that a zero
credit score is fine if you have cash
because already that's paid off so my
question was do i let this car go that
doesn't work and let them take it even
though it's going to mess with my credit
or do i pay it off
um that's my question
okay so what do you owe on the car that
works
the car that works is i still lie i
still about twenty four thousand that's
fairly new what do you make
i make 40 000 a year okay
have you got that car for sale yet
the one that doesn't work the one that
does work
you can't afford it no
okay no so what do you got like a 600
car payment right
uh it's
4.90 yeah okay
and and you make 40k this is a car you
can't afford
this is what's killing you so the car
that doesn't work what do you owe on it
i owe about 10. what is it
it's a hyundai tucson
what year
uh 15.
in the engine blue
yes um it's kind of a long story i don't
i mean well i'm just trying to ascertain
what to do is the en
you said the engine's bad what does that
mean i mean you dropped a rod it's a
complete meltdown or
it has to have a new engine or it just
needs heads put on i mean what's the
situation
no it needs a new engine
okay
all right uh
so that car fixed is probably worth 12
isn't it
uh yeah
okay
um that's my guess i'm not too yeah well
probably probably worth at least what
you owe on it and the one that's that
you owe 24 on what do you think it's
worth
um
i don't know how to maybe like 15. how
old are you
i'm 32. your family in the area
oh yeah actually i'm actually married
with three kids and a fourth on the way
like your parents are around your uncles
or ants are around or anything like that
um yeah yeah they're all around okay so
here's what i would tell you today
all right um you're gonna use some of
the 12 000 to get a used
engine
from a salvage yard a junkyard
that a
local mechanic not a dealer
puts in this car you can do that for two
to three thousand dollars
you're gonna fix that car
because if you turn it in right now it's
worth a thousand dollars they're gonna
sue you for the other nine thousand
dollars
and you're gonna have a repo
that is not a plan
not when you can spend a little bit of
your cash fix the car and then we're
either going to drive that car or we're
going to sell it because we're selling
the other one
you don't need a 24 000 car when you
make 40 a year
right that's broke people stuff right
there
so we got to get rid of that and you may
have to use some of your 12 000 to get
rid of that 24 000 card because you're
probably upside down on it
right
so if you write a check for two or three
thousand and get out of that car and a
check for two or three thousand and get
out of the other car you still got six
thousand dollars left in your savings
account
and um
you're either going to use that to go
buy a car for cash to drive or you're
going to drive the 10 000 car and start
working your way to paying it off
right after you put a used engine in it
so here's the deal somebody totaled a
car just like that and the car they
total only had 20 000 miles on it and so
the engine that's sitting in that
totaled car in that salvage yard is a
perfectly good engine
and it is the cheapest way to put an
engine in a used car
a used engine in a used car
and you can do that in the los angeles
area the reason i was asking about
family in the area is
my my uh advice is kind of old school
redneck advice and i was hoping one of
your your daddy or your uncle or
somebody actually had turned a wrench at
some point in their life and would know
how to pull off what i'm talking about
with a good local mechanic i'm not
suggesting they actually do the engine
change out but the point is that
somebody can get their head around this
because dude if you just walk away from
this you're going to get sued for 9
dollars and you're still gonna be
sitting on twenty four thousand our car
you can't afford
right
that's not a plan that's five years from
today that's you're gonna look back and
go both of those things were dumb
and if you to fix this in the next four
or five months the way i'm talking about
uh you would have no car payments or
very little car payment
gabriel i hope you really do it you
sound a little sleepy to me i hope you
really do it you've got a baby on the
way a fourth baby by the way
i hope you really do it get yourself out
of this mess
yeah yeah
there's not the problem is
you know larry burkett used to say and
he was a guy in the christian world that
taught on money
he said whatever time it takes you to
get into a mess it usually takes you
about the same time to get out
and i have learned that it did to
disagree with that it usually does take
you about half the time okay so if it
took you three years to make the mess it
might take you a year and a half to get
out okay but it usually doesn't take you
three years to get out and in his case
he's either going to continue making
messes yeah by being half asleep right
and turning this car in and continuing
to try to drive a 24 000 car he can't
afford right
uh because he's sleep deprived with a
house full of kids i don't know but um
or he's gonna throw his shoulders back
straighten that spine out and step into
this thing and go i'm gonna short i'm
gonna go into an a short term intense
amount of inconvenience and pain yeah
to limit my long-term damage well it's
like you always talk about you can
wander into debt you cannot wander out
people get into a mess
gradually incrementally by degrees
accidentally no one
few people go headlong into like i
really want to mess my life one looks at
something and goes that's really stupid
i'm going to do it anyway can't wait to
do it i can't wait no unless they're
doing drugs i mean no one just does it
right no it's gradual and so it takes
you three years of gradual missteps and
then you look over or it is a really
dumb idea but you just thought it was
smart at least you thought it was smart
you know i mean i've done a lot of stuff
in i've been an enthusiastic ignoramus
several times right
same sure
uh but then when you get when you decide
what you're gonna do to fix it you get
an intensity about you that lessens the
time it takes to get out that's what you
talk about with the gazelle intensity
that's what you talk about the you know
year and a half versus three years you
have an intensity and a drive and a fire
under you to fix it well like it's like
you know we're talking about running
this morning but but you're a big time
runner and you've done a lot more half
marathons or marathons than i've done
but uh but it's amazing to me that you
can run
uh
12 and a half miles
over for me that's a two hour yeah
arrangement right
and i'm turning the corner and after
running
jogging whatever
for two and a half hours or for two
hours and ten minutes or five minutes or
whatever i turn the corner
and i can still sprint yeah yeah
in my mind it's printing but i mean
at least i can run fast you know i can
i've still got something left in the
tank because i can see the finish line
that's right
that's right and and you know you go i'm
gonna shave just a few more seconds off
of this deal yeah and i'm gonna bust
that line right there and i'm gonna bust
into it yeah i'm not gonna stop and walk
across the line yeah you see people with
this paying off their debt they actually
end up doing it quicker than they
thought their goal because they get that
intensity last six months because they
started to believe that's right they
kick it in
and there's something that goes with
that it's pretty powerful you guys
so hey personal finance is 80 behavior
it's only 20 had knowledge most people
know what to do but for 30 years we've
been convincing them to do it around
here it's called the ramsay show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk they
use the same network as the larger
providers for much less for just thirty
dollars a month get unlimited talk text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over seventy
dollars a month by switching to pure top
just go to puretalk.com and enter the
promo code ramsey to save 50 off your
first month pure talk simply smarter
wireless
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions will
and samantha are with us hey guys what's
up how are you doing sir on the
debt-free stage it must mean one thing
and one thing only you're debt-free
how much do you pay off
we paid off uh 68 i'm sorry 62 800
good for you how long did this take
about 12 months good and your range of
income during that time we started at
100 000 and we ended up about 105 000.
cool what do y'all do for a living
i'm a teacher
but during our debt free time i actually
took a job as
a tutor during the summer so i was still
able to work 40 hours a week
i also picked up a job during the
holidays at a department store so it
could be done in a year also hustle yeah
yeah she worked about four jobs
hustle and grind i love it what kind of
debt was the 63 000 student loan debt
all of it all of it and where do you
guys live
louisville kentucky okay and how long
have you guys been married
november of 19. so about a year and a
half a little over a year and a half
intense first year and a half of
marriage working on this that's awesome
yeah yeah
so you said you're a teacher and what do
you do well i work for a community bank
up in louisville okay great very cool so
what happened a year ago what got you
fired up to do this
well i grew up listening to dave my
dad's a cpa
i remember we'd be leaving church
and dave ramsey be playing on sunday in
the car
the second sermon
yeah
i said we'd be backing out and there's
some redneck from antioch tennessee
that's on the radio leaving
he was he was obsessed um for a long
time and he before we got married he was
like we're gonna do the dave ramsey and
i was like no we are not
i love money and um so a couple years
ago i actually had um i have type 1
diabetes and so i had an incident where
i was out of work for a couple weeks a
stomach bug that just didn't turn out
too well and we just talked about it and
we didn't want to be in a situation
where we couldn't afford the debt
because i couldn't work or something and
i don't want to put will in that
situation also so that's when i kind of
jumped on board too yeah it gives you a
different level of motivation when you
think of it through that lens oh no
definitely now i mean if that were to
happen now it wouldn't really even be a
big deal right like it stink because
you'd be in the hospital but outside of
that you know we could write a check for
it the money part would that's a problem
that's right you could focus on healing
focus on getting the care that you need
and not worry about the bills yes yeah
that's good so
12 months ago you made that decision for
that reason
and then what did you do did y'all jump
through financial peace or did you
what'd you do yeah we got a financial
piece through our church southeast okay
uh went out there with pete and
i remember uh the toughest moment
was when we made that first payment we
put all of our wedding money towards it
and we went down to a thousand dollars
in our uh savings account it was really
really tough
um because she was crying
like and that was just rough you know
being a newly married guy and uh yep
laying next to your bride who's crying
because of that you know that was just
really rough now it kind of lit a fire
underneath both of us to get it done
with and uh just put everything towards
it yeah i cried a lot
yeah what was the what was the reason
for that cry
i was more frustrated myself so i have
two different degrees and so i was
really frustrated in the first part of
not looking at student loans differently
because we just
so as if i feel guilty cry oh definitely
because he came in the marriage with no
debt and i was like uh we're a little
bit in debt because of me and so that's
really why i took on so many jobs and he
was like let me let me deliver pizza and
i was like no it's my dad
so he was being so nice towards it yeah
she wouldn't let me work another job
wow so yeah that that's a
but at least you're processing it
and at that moment when you put that
wedding money out there and we're doing
this together we're locking arms we're
going to do this and
it sucks but we're doing it and that's
kind of that's kind of one of us i was
so frustrated we uh listed all the debt
because you know it was a nail net we
listed all the different loans out
and when i listed them out i was just
like dadgummit that's just
we're not gonna yeah just kind of get
mad yeah and you did it in 12 months
yeah i mean did you sell stuff how much
did you have in savings um i think we
put about 10
what's the first payment and then um so
you cash flow 50 grand yeah well i mean
they're all principal payments covid was
the best thing that ever happened to us
yeah um there's no interest accruing on
them
everything was principal payment from
about i don't know when they started
doing that craziness like may or june
yeah mayor june on um which then we just
really looked at each other and hunkered
down i was like they're not accruing any
interest everything's a principal
payment
we need to pay these off as fast as
possible that's good but still on that
income that's impressive y'all paid that
off in 12 months on that income that is
you went down to beans and rice you did
yes lots of leftovers i told people like
we would go to sam's club and buy the
huge things of meat and we would
literally eat on it all week because it
was the cheapest thing you could buy
and so that's really what we did
sharon used to get that dad gum frozen
chicken bags of those breasts of chicken
yeah at sam's or costco yeah and and i i
hate that
we would eat it so much i haven't heard
you talk about that i've heard you talk
about the tuna fish the tuna fish was
really broke this was it this was a
little bit later but yeah we had this
she's still a tight wash that's a
problem but yeah she is buy a filet
mignon
bring me the cheaper chicken you're
going to be ruined from that costco meat
now i know right
yeah we are
that's all right that's right we did it
that's all
one guy i heard one time he said i want
to get wealthy enough where i read the
menu from the left to the right yep yeah
instead of starting with the prices on
the menu and figuring out what i'm gonna
eat i'm gonna figure out what i want to
eat because the price doesn't matter
yeah yeah that's a good that's a good
place to work for baby step seven yeah
good for you guys well done how's it
feel now that you did it
oh it feels great amazing tears of joy
yeah okay there you go trust me on
december 31st i was crying again and i
was like i can't believe we did it
because is that when you hit the submit
button on the last one yeah new year's
eve
yeah that's why i got the job at macy's
because i told him i was like we are so
close if i can just get this department
job we're not going to wake up on
january 1st
with a with a
payment and so that's really you started
this year debt free yes you could see
that you could see the finish line you
spread it into it we were just talking
about that yeah wow that is so cool how
excited were your parents oh they were
super bad oh everyone we had a bunch of
my uncle and i had a race you could pay
his farm off
if we could pay our debt off first
he beat us by a couple of days okay
but man yeah it was uh no there everyone
was super proud of us yeah nobody lost
that race
no we didn't no and he didn't either um
but yeah it was uh everyone's super
proud of us um you know we're just
really thankful because my parents
you know you were
you're about same age as them um
they would they modeled that for me
growing up
you know my dad just bought himself his
first new car
you know yeah and he's an everyday
millionaire now oh
he's yeah easy i don't know you know
we've talked about that stuff but yeah
yeah but he is yeah we you and i both
know yeah
he's listening so he'll be excited you
said that well i mean if he's not he
really did a bad job of listening all
these years so
he didn't retain it
so
we probably couldn't hear over over uh
three boys fighting in the background
it's interesting the three boys the
financial peace babies are showing up
these days they're on the uh on the debt
free stage and how old are you two
twenty eight all right i'm so proud of
y'all she's going on friday yeah well
happy birthday thank you well done well
done you did all this before your 30 and
you got the whole rest of your life to
do it smart yeah so very very good tears
of joy followed from tears of shame
i understand i've had both myself very
well done
all right it's will and samantha we got
a copy of the legacy journey book
because that's the next stage in your
life is to move on now and build a
full-on legacy really continue the
legacy your dad started that's in a
sense very well done and a copy of the
total money makeover so you can pay it
forward by giving that to somebody who
needs their wake-up call
so good stuff very good stuff well in
samantha louisville kentucky 63 000 paid
off in 12 months making 100-105 count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream
[Music]
[Applause]
this is how it's done
that is so fun
so well done you two
so well done
at last spence last sprint took the job
at christmas you turned the corner
that's right and you see that last bit
and you can see the yellow tape you see
you're gonna make it and you you bust
into it and even if it's macy's you bust
into it yup this
is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you can take the challenge to get back
24 hours in your week if you text time
finder to thirty three four forty four
that's a an item chrissy has put
together to help you find some time
time finder 233 444. we were talking
earlier in the hour about
balance and life balance and applying
your time like you apply your money to
the things that matter most to you kevin
is in buffalo new york hey kevin how are
you
good how are you better than i deserve
what's up
good so i just got a question about life
insurance so before i really listen to
you so my i'm an electrician by trade
and i work quite a bit i'm only 23 years
old i um work and i also have some
family friends who do a lot of
property management so i work on the
side for them as well good
so
um yeah like i said i'm 23 currently i'm
making about 17 1800 a week after taxes
including the part-time side jobs
um
so my life insurance policy i got two
years ago before i listened to you
his whole life
um
it's a thirteen thousand dollar a year
premium
but it's a twenty pay
one million dollar death benefit covers
long-term care
um and obviously has a cash value
but then when i started hearing you say
um
to go term instead invest the difference
it's now in my head
about what i should do
so i don't know what i should do
okay
well um number one you're 23 you don't
need to worry about long-term care
insurance that's asinine okay
that they sold a 23-year-old a long-term
care insurance policy absolutely asinine
but that's what these people do
and so the uh the second thing is this
13
000 dollars for a million dollars on a
23 year old did i get that right
yeah um but i guess have you priced term
insurance on a 23 year old
no i have but like
the only reason i liked it is no no no
no i wasn't asking why you like it
i said have you priced
a million dollars on a 23 year old term
life insurance with zander insurance
there's
like 30 40 dollars
yeah like three 400 bucks a year yeah
yeah okay which means that
uh twelve thousand
almost thirteen thousand dollars is
going into a savings account inside that
policy did you notice how much your
savings account your cash value buildup
is for the first year
did you notice that it was zero
yes
do you not feel screwed because you were
that's why i'm saying well i'm serious
you got you put you put 12
600 in a savings account and the balance
is zero
this is bad math this is bad math yeah
and you're going to do it again next
year
please don't tell me there's any reason
in your brain that thinks this is a good
idea
no i mean no get rid of this crap
are you married today
no i'm single uh we'll just cancel it
today
okay today if you want to get some
insurance you don't need a million
dollars on you to start with because you
don't you're not leaving anybody behind
that's gonna not eat because you don't
do electrician stuff you you know you
know you might need a little bit to bury
you so your mom and dad don't have to
pay for it do you have a bunch of debt
zero good how much money you have in
savings
um well i started working at 19 i have
195 000 in mutual funds good for you
i think your parents will be able to
bury you you don't okay
you don't need life insurance son
at all okay at all okay and now when
you're married and have a couple kids
and your wife is counting on you to make
90 000 a year to feed her and those kids
yeah now maybe we'll pick up a million
dollars at that point and buy you a 15
or a 20-year level term policy for three
or four hundred dollars a year in the
meantime i just made you twelve thousand
six hundred bucks a year and that i'm
gonna i'm a magician that way i'm just
i'm that guy i just made up twelve
thousand dollars i just pulled it out of
the air and handed it to you and you
paid how much for this
nothing because this show is free
oh my gosh
just like that just like that 30 seconds
i think now now that savings account is
going to grow even more so a cash value
policy in its first three years has cash
value build up of zero
sometimes in the third year it'll build
up a little bit in the first two years
it's always zero and i knew his was zero
because he's in the first year
and here's the bad part
some duber
that he went to high school with went
and got his license and went and sold
all his friends yep yep and he brought
his boss over to sell him yep
yeah and so he got in the door some
duber that's got the door on
relationship and brought the big boss in
who put the arm twist on him and
convinced him that this was a good idea
that he needed a million dollars at 23
with no kids yeah
for what and that this is a great and of
course we're gonna get we're gonna put
long-term care insurance on there too
yeah because that matters when you're
23.
yeah nursing home care is a big deal
when you're 23.
jeez
so don't we listen i totally believe in
long-term care insurance never buy it
with another policy do not bundle it
with anything they're bundling it with
everything out there trying to make it
work and it's not working don't do it
you always buy your long-term care
insurance after you're 60 years old that
was going to be my question 23. okay
yeah 62.
ouch austin
in austin i can't believe i did that
what's up man how are you
i'm doing well how are you doing good
how can we help
uh well i'll give you a quick background
i'm 26 my wife is 22 and we just had our
first baby this past march
congratulations thanks for a little
sacrifice
yeah you are
um so i'm currently working two jobs um
i'm working a full-time entry level
position with a salary of about 40 000
which ends up being like 37 000 take
home uh and i'm waiting i'm waiting
tables part time making around 20 to 22
uh per year so
uh my question uh
i'm my job i'm a paraplaner i just got
my fdqp credential at a wealth building
firm
and my boss wants me to start trying to
become an actual uh financial advisor uh
so if i start this certification uh i'm
pretty sure my starting pay will be a
good bit higher than what i'm making
combined with my two jobs
and i'm just i guess the main thing that
worries me is that uh you know my salary
is forty thousand and that if i were to
uh if i were to go this route i'm not
sure if i should uh cut my current
full-time job uh sorry full-time if i
should cut my part-time job
when would you get the raise
if you go into this program to get
certified when would you get the raise
a supervisor made it sound like it would
happen as soon as i earned
how
the
how long does it take you to do that
you know i i want to say it's a couple
years i think i could knock it out in
less than two years okay
and so if you quit the
other job you're 22 000 short during
that time
exactly which is my concern i'm not sure
um because if i did if i did quit my
wedding cables job then i wouldn't
really have the funds to
cover all of my expenses and on top of
that um my my salary by itself would
kind of go over that 25.
i'm i'm running out of time what's your
question then
uh my question is should i ask for a
raise in my current position because i'm
a pretty valuable team member at this
point would that be appropriate or
should i keep my part job a part-time
job and work less hours it's always
appropriate to ask for a raise if you're
worth it
now worth it is not i'm worth it because
i like myself like a saturday night live
skit this is like you can say this
position pays this at other firms and so
i'd like to get paid a little more i i
want to add value but the way you ask
for it is what can i do to be worth more
to you guys because i need to make some
more and i want to make myself more
valuable to you guys i kind of thought i
was doing that but if there's something
else i can do to make myself more
valuable because i need to get i want to
ditch this waiting tables job so i can
get in this cert program and i can't
afford to do that the way things are now
what can i do to become more valuable to
you and they'll usually will step up
don't you think yes and austin get
clarity you don't sound like you know
the date of when you would get the raise
or how much the raise would be it's like
well i think i assume i want you to ask
ask what will this what is the path i'm
on for advancement financially and from
a credential standpoint be sure to enter
this credential program can we go ahead
and give me the right yeah get clarity
there specifically ask that becomes a
no-brainer
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show this episode is over but
if you heard about an event product or
service and didn't have a chance to
write it down don't worry we list
everything you've heard about during
this episode in the podcast show notes
section or head to theramsieshow.com
thanks for listening
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host christy wright ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author
host of the christy wright show one of
the ramsey network podcasts that is uber
popular
is my co-host today open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five jake starts us off in garden city
kansas hey jake how are you
i'm better than i deserve james how
about yourself just the same sir just
the same how can we help
i am 24 years young and i've done a lot
of dumb in my life
i'm a mechanic i've
i got a question on on if i'm doing the
right thing here i've got
twenty almost twenty two thousand
dollars in bet on my tools um which i
have to have to do my job so i'm paying
that off as quick as i can
uh i'm
in a place right now that my house i
have two offers on it for to where i can
get out and get a fair amount of equity
out of it
right now i'm paying
on it and i'm paying the pmi on it and
all that and i'm on a 30-year mortgage i
didn't get into it very smartly
but i have good equity in it and for
what i'm getting offered in this market
it is a very good deal
and i'm going i i found another place
actually
30 minutes down the road in in another
town that
would still allow me to get to work
easily
and it is already a place that i have
equity in and with the equity i'm
pulling out of this place
would be able to put a
significant down payment on it get out
of the pmi
uh
then i also have my pickup right now i'm
uh
i was upside down in it and the market
is going on i'm sorry you're gonna have
to stop jake what is it you need
um
when i sell my house do i do i invest
into another house if i can get good
equity into it and get under the pmi or
do i use it to pay off credit card debt
i've got five thousand credit card debt
and some snap on tool debt do i use that
towards the debts there or do i use that
to get into another house that i can be
paying on how much are you going to get
out of this house
uh approximately 35 to a little over 35
000. and you're 24 years old and you're
single
yeah uh single but i have a seven month
old son
okay
and um you make what a year
i make about 70 uh 75 to 78. good for
you okay
all right
and you got 22 in tools and how much
other debt
uh 27 on my pickup which i think i can
sell and get out of get a cheaper
vehicle
and five thousand in credit cards okay
so if you pay off the tools and the
credit cards you're renting right now
that would be correct if i did that yeah
you sell the truck and you build up your
emergency fund and then you build up a
down payment and that's what i would do
yes yeah i know i would not i would not
buy another house right now
um
and let me just tell you um
from a business perspective and knowing
a tiny bit about your business and
one of my
best friends was in the snap-on business
for a while
uh those guys are um
they are very very good at what they do
which is selling you tools
and uh that that line of i have to have
these tools to make my living
is partially true
but it's not true of 22 000 worth
some of that was bought because you just
wanted one and in your world
adding to that toolbox
unless it absolutely comes out of that
toolbox and causes your income to go up
more than the cost of that tool sometime
in the next 90 days is bs
yes sir
people in your world over buy tools
yes sir all the time
it's not that you don't need good tools
the snap-on's good tools it's good
quality stuff but they will sell you a
line that y'all you have to spend money
to make money
and this is this is what you do your
craft with and all of those lines are
technically true
but it causes you to buy
a good 30 more than you need in most
people in your business and
subcontractors do it in the construction
business uh computer people do it uh
people in the video world do it they buy
a bunch of crap and they you spend by a
bunch of equipment and they spend all of
their profits back out in equipment and
it's not stuff you have to have to do
business we've talked about this before
dave even with women that i work with
through business boutique there's an
element of buying stuff whether it's
equipment supplies whatever
that we over buy because it somehow
justifies the business because it
somehow makes us feel like this is real
i'm really doing it i'm a real fill in
the blank it's kind of like i used the
example but when i needed to go needed
to go buy a suit to interview for my
first job out of college like i didn't
have interview clothes and i just want
to feel like i've got a new suit i've
got a new computer back you don't need
that to do your job
and so when you start looking at when
you run your own business that that
money is coming out of your paycheck
because it's taking away from the
profitability of the business then you
start thinking how many tools do i
really need to have is this going to roi
or can i get by with with less and not
justify the validity of the business
with purchases because what
justifies the validity of the business
is money yeah so here's the thing you
got 22 000 worth in your box you're
making 78 you probably don't need
anymore for a while yeah yeah not gonna
make mr snap-on very happy yeah
but my goal is not to make him happy my
goals make you happy can you sell some
back you think uh no but they're those
guys are on a route and so they'll swing
by and see him every so often and
selling
we got a new thing you gotta have this
you need this thing yeah here's what's
happening with that look what you could
potentially make with this yeah you you
can
there's certain tools that you know
a 70 year old version of it will
actually still work perfect right right
other tools need to be brand new right
and so um but you just have to be
careful because that's the business that
they're in and they're very very good at
it well and i would be willing but
there's an element of business analysis
to this where you go okay they snap on
tools salesman guy comes by and he's
like oh we've got this new thing that
does this new thing and you go i don't
have a request for that you know what i
mean like the requests that i have are
oil changes the brakes are bad i need
new you know rotors okay you got the
tools for that cool do get the tools for
the things you actually use not the new
widget that someone's trying to sell you
because you don't have people coming in
with that doesn't matter yeah oftentimes
that's very very true so be careful with
that's all i'm warning you on jake but i
think you're right you sell the house
you become debt free you sell the truck
you become debt free get you a beater
finish your emergency fund up uh then
save your down payment and that's
probably a year to a two year process
for you right now from today but during
that two years you're going to be so
unbroke
because you won't have any payments
right that it's going to be a wonderful
place to be
and you're carrying more stress maybe
even than you realize right now between
the credit card the tool debt the truck
and the house and when you step out of
all of that and you're just a renter
uh for a couple years and you say okay
by the time i'm 26 i'll be back into a
house and i'm paying a really good
strong down payment no pmi and i won't
have any debt and it's completely
different decision making than it is to
doing it today yeah and kind of what
you're doing is you're cutting halfway
through the thing and i'm just saying
cut all the way through it yeah cut all
the way through it yeah so good good
questions
good question
christy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education the army
national guard the army national guard
believes you are the next greatest
generation because you have proven that
even in adversity that you have what it
takes to succeed that's why they offer
benefits like tuition assistance career
training and a paycheck to help you
avoid debt no matter what your goals are
the army national guard can help you get
there visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five thank
you for joining us america we're glad
you're here nicole is with us in
jacksonville florida hi nicole how are
you
i'm doing well how are you dave better
than i deserve what's up
dave i just want to thank you for your
principles my husband and i are on baby
step three
my husband's father died very
unexpectedly 19 days ago oh i'm sorry
thank you
um my mother-in-law is 63 years old
her lifelong partner somebody two years
died with no life insurance
she has
car loan debt consumer credit card debt
and a home loan
and her social security check is equal
to her mortgage
so we are
questioning you sir if this was your
family would you suggest us to have her
file bankruptcy
and stay in the home and have to you
know stretch it and
um barely make ends meet or would we
sell the house and
my husband and i are in a position where
we have a walk-out basement
and we've
given the opportunity for her to use
those proceeds of selling the home and
pay off her debt and then use proceeds
at the home to renovate our basement
into a one-bedroom apartment
where she can live with us but not with
us um so we were just curious to see
what your opinion would be on everything
stated
well the uh what's the equity in the
house
she's got about 150 000 equity
okay and uh she has a car debt and what
other debt
6700 on the car and roughly 33 000 in
credit card debt that she can't make the
minimum payments even on right okay and
she was working for her husband and a
very small plumbing company and when she
lost her spouse she also lost her
employment
he was a one-man show so the business
has been dissolved what was she doing
just running the office
just running the office
yes sir okay all right
oh what a horrible thing for her i'm so
sorry
yes sir
we're so grateful that we were following
your plan and on baby step three that we
could come in and help with his
afterlife care it was such a blessing to
be in that position and not have to go
into that to do so
yeah um she's gonna have a good pile of
money even after she's debt-free the
house is gone she can't she can't afford
to keep everything and no she's not
bankrupt she has 150 worth of equity
she's not even close to bankrupt
um and bankruptcy would cause her to
lose the house to the bankruptcy so no
we don't we're not doing that
so she just need she's got to sell the
house it's sad
um and that pays off the debt and then
she's got a hundred thousand plus in her
hand
um and she gets a job
right
she doesn't want to work she's 63. i'm
sorry
she can work
and 63 is not old enough to retire when
you're broke
she's hurting and she's grieving and and
and that makes sense but
um she's getting she's gonna need to do
something for money number one but
number two to keep herself occupied
she's still young
right she doesn't need to sit on her
butt from 63 to 93.
you know it's not that's not good for
humans
we need to do something
absolutely and so um
yeah just just to but that but right now
she's just hurting
so i mean we'll be gentle with her but
that that's um we're not doing that
so um if i if it was my mom i would not
move her into the basement
no because i don't think it's necessary
she's got a hundred thousand dollars and
when she starts working she can get her
a little rental apartment
set the hundred thousand dollars aside
and in a couple of years start thinking
about buying a home again
okay with 100 down and it'll be a
different price range home than she's in
now but without the credit card debt
without the car debt with the uh pain
and the tragedy in her rear view mirror
and she's back functioning again in a
career
uh by 65 she easily could buy a house
nicole have y'all talked to her about
the basement plan or has she asked to
move in has that been appointed
discussion yet
oh it's definitely we offered we off
we've got a thousand square foot walkout
basement underneath our house yeah um
so and it's unfinished it's a dirt floor
so yeah she's not penniless she doesn't
need to live in a basement
well even if she we made it into a
mother-in-law suite with her proceeds
from the house i just i just wouldn't
it goes back to what you say a lot of
times dave would you do that if if it
wasn't your mother-in-law
would you have someone just move into
your basement and build it out with
their money you wouldn't
and she hasn't love her dearly we think
the world of herself listen
if she was on the street
and homeless absolutely we would do this
but she's got a hundred thousand dollars
worth of options
okay is i guess my question is nicole is
like what is the why of her moving in
with y'all is she unable to take care of
herself she doesn't want to work and
this puts her up to where she doesn't
want to work she you know she has the
you know the old-fashioned mindset that
brenton is throwing money away it's not
the time to be buying right now we all
acknowledge that's not smart to do right
now
um but just looking at rentals you know
she doesn't you know it would be more
than what her current mortgage is and
she doesn't want to have to get into
that
that nest egg every month just to cover
the basics you know
and i mean so it just made sense to okay
renovate the basement
and you know get her a nice one-bedroom
studio apartment down there and
then she you know then she would own it
and then she's elderly and you know
needs our help we're right there she
doesn't own it um
well
you own it
right and she's only 62 years old
yeah this doesn't play well for 30 years
and when she gets ready to move on with
her life now she's got her money stuck
in your basement
true
true that's i i just i wouldn't make
this decision today i would go rent an
apartment for six months after you sell
the house and be debt free stabilize
let's get a better brighter future
picked out rather than i'm going to hide
in the basement for 30 years
okay that's just that's mentally what
she's doing it's escape
it'd be different if it was necessary
nicole that's where i go back to be
different necessary she needs your care
for her house she can never tell you i
would never tell you not to take care of
your mom because she's right you have
she's a hundred thousand dollars of cash
and she's young she can work
there's no actual need base for this
decision she's debt-free
you adore her and she doesn't want to
work this is more of a choice than a
need rents a little apartment over by
the ocean
over by the beach somewhere and goes for
long walks and starts to reset her mind
and heal from this grieving go through
the grieving process and and just give
her some time
and she needs to put her hand to
something and go make some money so that
she doesn't burn through the hundred
thousand right but um but i don't want
her to rent for the rest of her life i
wouldn't suggest that and and and let's
say that she became ill or something was
unable to care for herself yeah okay or
after six months if we're still thinking
this way if you all want to do it it's
not the end of the world but the problem
is is it
it closes down her future
it narrows the focus on her future to
where she's acting like she's 83 not 63.
well it's gonna be it may be hard for
her to find a job and it might be hard
for her to rent those things now that
she doesn't want to do and has never
done before it's gonna be a whole lot
harder in five years after you guys have
gotten all comfortable in the basement
then she won't she won't
go buy something then because the
money's in your basement yeah it's at 30
grand of the seven you know now we got
70 left
and now you feel bad because you got her
money in your basement
um and now you got to go sell your house
to get her money out or something like
that because she wants to move on with
her life but i i think there's a second
act here a third act an encore
i don't think that this is the final
curtain for her that's my point and so
we don't want to build something out
here that that acts like it's final
curtain stuff and that's what that's
what you're doing you're trapping her so
if you're gonna do it i'd wait six
months let's rent for six months let's
get some of the grieving behind us
you're gonna have to sell the house you
gotta sell the house get that free but
get that free go rent something put the
hundred thousand a cd for six months sit
on it live on the social security check
begin to think about career and then
make this decision and if you want to do
it i'm not really mad at you but i
wouldn't i think it's narrowing her
options too tightly
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage brian and andrea are
with us hey guys how are you doing great
how are you better than i deserve where
you guys from at moore alabama at moore
now where's that more it's about an hour
away from mobile oh okay all right
wonderful well thanks for being in
nashville to do your debt-free scream
how much have you paid off fifty three
thousand eight hundred dollars good
awesome and how long did this take you
24 months yay and your range of income
during that time starting at 50 now
we're at 65. cool what do y'all do for a
living
uh i'm an accountant
and i'm a game attendant at wind creek
casino wonderful good to have you guys
well way to go guys how long you all
been married
eight years okay all right what kind of
debt was the 54 000
it was uh my car a mattress
our shed his truck and then we finally
finished it off with the house you paid
off the house and everything he did
everything wow
wow
it's not much of a house but it's all
ours now it sure is it's it's paid for
by god there you go what's your house
worth uh our guess is about 80 000. like
i said it's not much but it's ours how
old are you two i'm 27 and i'm 29. i
gotta tell you you're way ahead yes you
are you don't need to apologize for that
house it's a paid for dadgum house
that's awesome i'm so proud of y'all
thank you well done okay so you're
married eight years but something
after six years two years ago
changed
what let the fuse on this so i started
it i kind of um it was funny because
there was nothing that really happened
there was no tragic moment i just kind
of just got tired of stressing about the
credit card bills being due and all the
other bills being done the accountant
huh what am i going to pay what is he
going to pay because we had separate
bank accounts all the time
so a lot has changed since then we
combined incomes combined bank accounts
and cut up the credit cards and did the
whole shebang
wow
so uh how did you get connected to us
uh google and i sell google okay so that
night you were just that night you're
doing the bills you just got frustrated
and googled what well it was actually
march 3rd 2019 and i'll be honest i
don't pray too often but i did pray i
said god i don't know what it is i don't
know what i need to do i don't know what
direction we need to take but there's
something that needs to happen with us
financially i need you to help guide me
and the next day i found dave ramsey wow
so i can quite say that you and your
entire team have been an answer prayer
you just your team is just wonderful wow
wow we're honored that's amazing we're
honored if god would use us that makes
us uh worth showing up it's good for you
guys well done very well done i'm so
proud of you so you all went from
financing the shed credit cards putting
everything on you know payments
when you're financing the [ __ ] i know i
heard that you're financing everything i
know well that's but then they went but
then they paid off their house like tell
me about
who we're putting everything on debt to
all the way to paying off the house like
y'all didn't mess around y'all went all
in oh no yeah well we did the debt
snowball and starters from smallest to
largest and then uh we and we were
finally done with that where we're like
well let's just go over the house it's
not much more so let's just go ahead and
finish it all off and be done with
everything it's just going to be
completely debt free wow
that's amazing yeah and i also want to
say that something that really has
helped me personally is practicing
minimalism i know you had the minimalist
on here every now and then absolutely
that's something that i discovered a
couple years ago and uh i took some time
off of social media i took a little
break and i discovered minimalism and it
becomes less of a burden once you start
selling things because you don't really
have to you really want to so anyone
that's never heard of minimalism i would
highly recommend looking into it yeah
those guys are great guys they're
wonderful there's just something
peaceful about that whole
elementary it process the mental
simplicity that gives you in life yeah
you don't think of the effect that
physical clutter has on your mental
state your emotional state but it does
they're actually the guest of the
christie on the christy right show that
aired this week just yesterday and just
after talking to them when we recorded
it i was like i went home and i was like
what can i cut out what can i get rid of
it it's so inspiring right yeah
yeah i told him i'm i'm kind of a
maximum yeah i'm not surprised by that i
have to
but but i i think it's hard to hang out
with those two and not go home and look
at your closet and go half of this stuff
needs to be thrown out 100 percent you
haven't worn that you haven't worn that
coat in 17 years you've probably ought
to get rid of it you aren't going to
wear it this week no you don't need it
just in case kind of show up yeah it's
it's borderline hoarding that we all do
really well i'm proud of you guys way to
go y'all so what do you tell people the
key to getting out of debt is i mean
you're not even 30 you got a paid for
house uh communication
big big factor uh the cash envelopes
really doing the cash because our first
trip to sam's i got the necessities like
the frozen chicken breast that you were
talking about earlier i got all those
necessities out of the way and i wanted
a little bit of a little bit of extras
and for the first time that humility
sank in once i had to take something off
of the register so put it back
yeah once that actually happened that
just hurt my pride a little bit but it
all worked out yeah it turns out that
nobody at sam's is going to run home and
go that woman had to put stuff back you
wouldn't believe it nobody cares nobody
gives a rip nobody gives a rip as a
matter of fact most of us have been
there oh yeah yeah there's one person on
the planet that cares about that and
it's you that's it yeah that's that's
amazing but it's so it is embarrassing
it's a moment i don't remember that
feeling and it's one thing talking about
it but then actually going through it oh
it just hurts but
it's so worth it once you actually take
you actually switch over to the cash
envelopes yeah well it's short term it's
short term that you're making those type
of that level of sacrifice to real you
know what i mean and so then now it's
like you have more money because all
that money's not going to debt oh yeah
it's not forever and i also want to say
um i don't talk eventually maybe
i want to say that no matter your income
and no matter what level of ratio from
shovel to income
anything you set your mind to you can't
accomplish it because i was i was
thinking we don't make that much we're
not going to have this paid off in you
know a couple years i would never
thought that would happen i was that
person and
anyone that's listening you can do it it
is possible just you have to stick with
it and so brian did she sell all your
stuff yeah
not all of it
not all of it
but uh just most of it yeah stuff i
didn't need oh there you go all right
there you go
that's fun so very very well done so you
googled and you found the podcast or you
found what with us youtube youtube i
just i i really i started watching
youtube videos and i learned everything
from that and i talked i mean i looked
into fpu but i was like i don't even
want to spend the money and all the
information's on youtube for free so i
just did that instead
and i really i wanted to leave an fpu
class i attempted to i signed up for it
a couple people came in they
unfortunately wouldn't work they
couldn't they couldn't stick with it
something happened in their life which
is fine but i would love to teach i
tried i tried to teach an fbu class so
hopefully hopefully someone will hear
this and want to do a class there you go
i would love to well that'd be fun we'd
love to have you coordinate one so well
done you guys how does it feel how does
it feel to get to keep your money now it
feels amazing yeah it was incredible so
who were your biggest cheerleaders
uh well we have my grandparents over
here today with us they were this
throughout the entire process they were
just cheering us on the entire time i
love it they've always been frugal their
entire lives so the fact that we were
being
power go baby go
my mom she did she tried to do the cash
envelope a year many many years ago
whenever yeah a long time ago but she's
wonderful too she was a big cheerleader
throughout all so they made the road
trip up here with you to nashville get
to see nashville and get this throw
their shoulders back stick out their
chest and be proud of you too yeah they
wanted to be here with us amen amen
nothing better than that
and you had a yeah and i had a buddy of
mine at work who was also very
supportive of it i wasn't all in at
first uh takes me a minute i'm
open-minded but it takes me a minute to
get to actually get with the program but
uh sure i started talking to a buddy of
mine named danny at work he
then he actually was doing this and uh
he explained to me that it's real worth
it really worth it to do all this and
it's going to be
just absolutely amazing in the end when
we were finished so was he right he was
definitely right all right
that's awesome well done well we got a
copy of the legacy journey because
that's the next chapter in your all
story legacy is changed well done you're
young and you got a paid for freaking
house it's awesome you guys are you guys
are amazing star heroes man
50 and a copy of the total money
makeover for you to give away to
somebody and help you can be you can be
danny to somebody you can give them a
total money makeover and encourage them
get them going and uh that's what it's
for so very very cool brian and andrea
from alabama 54 000 paid off in 24
months making 50 to 65. count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream three two
one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you and me weren't answered a prayer hey
how about that i like it i like it
[Music]
[Music]
chrissy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today debbie is in boise idaho
hi debbie welcome to the ramsay show
hi thank you for taking my call sure
what's up i've got a few questions well
one is i'm trying i've tried your
program for probably five or six years
now trying to get my husband on board i
can't get him to look at a budget
or even
sit down and look at the ability that
he's a spender
he's the free spirit and i'm the
nerd
so that's the first thing and just i've
done things like refinance the house
paid up saved money and paid off credit
cards and
gotten rid of them all except for a
couple and then he's created more
and so i feel like i'm just going
backwards how old is how old is he
he's going to be 60 and i'm 55.
how long y'all been married
24 years
you know i honestly expected you to say
he was 26 because he's acting like a
child
well i know and it's almost caused a
divorce at one point um i can imagine
that he did not consult you on
yep he paid for it the third credit
everything's credit
um and that's what's concerning me is
he's self-employed and his income he's
not as physical as he used to be so our
income is
decreasing so i'm stressed trying to get
rid of the bills because i know we're
getting older
and i'm just not able to get
rid of them when i turn around and
create another card i'll pay one off and
he'll create another
debbie this is not a money problem this
is a marriage problem
a big marriage problem the fact that
he's not consulting with you listening
to you considering what's important to
you this is he does not value
you by his actions right now and that is
a major problem
yeah
this is not just about you're trying to
pay off bills
go ahead
honey you can't dig out of the hole i
mean you can't fill up the whole faster
and he can dig it out no oh
yeah and it doesn't it doesn't matter
how quick you you pay it off if he
continues to do this and the level of
disrespect you must feel when he does
it's not again it's not just about the
spending man god that level of
disrespect
that he showed
to not pay some bills so that he
couldn't get more credit
on certain bills because i was trying to
pay off other bills like
if you you're working real hard not to
address the real issue aren't you
yeah yeah i guess so
okay are you do you guys happen to
attend a church
um i'm trying to but i can't get him on
board with that either yeah okay
so here's what you need to do hon okay
this is a lot more than christie and i
can fix
in a radio call
this is 24 years
of misbehavior
and he's he's your husband i i'm his age
he's misbehaving
if one of my friends was treating his
wife this way i would be up in his grill
if one of my closest buddies and i got i
got about 10 or 15 guys i run with
pretty tight and if one of those guys
was acting the reason i run tight with
them is they don't treat their wives
this way
um and i can tell you this if i treated
sharon ramsey this way i'd have to be
dealing with one mad hillbilly woman
after about the first round it wouldn't
have lasted 24 years lasted 24 minutes
right
and that's why i think
you know
do you work debbie
i do matter of fact i'm well he's
self-employed uh and i'm self-employed
realtor i we just sold our business of
12 years
uh and moved to a different state
and bought it you know sold our house
that was worth more and bought and to
reduce that
let me cycle back the reason i was
asking where you if you were in church
was not a a spiritual statement i'm
trying to find somewhere you can get
community to uh get get somebody to talk
with him but uh so what you need to do
is you need to find a good faith-based
marriage counselor
as soon as possible you're 20 years late
coming to that meeting
he's not going to do that either
but you go anyway
because you need someone long form not a
radio answer to begin to help you
formulate conversations with him
because you're either going to live a
miserable broke stress-filled life for
the next 24 years
or you're going to force his hand on
this he's going to change or it's going
to end
one of the two things is going to happen
here yeah and you the problem is is
you're really late
and it's going to be very hard to get
him to hear
because he's never had to hear you've
cried wolf so many times you've dug him
out so many times i don't know if he's
going to hear it or not but you need to
get someone to teach you how crazy
you're being treated this is cray cray
it's wrong
yeah no and the reason i asked if she
worked because i thought well let me dig
into this is there
does he think because he makes the money
no that he can do whatever it does it
doesn't matter why but you you have to
address the real issue this is not just
a financial issue this is a partnership
you're not this is a lack of value this
is a lack of communication
y'all are not a marriage you're not a
partnership you're not
the things that make a marriage y'all
don't have
trust
communication
mutual respect you don't have those
things you may have a marriage
certificate but you don't have those
things and so a counselor can help you
figure out what this looks like for you
what accidentally
begin to speak to him in a way that
maybe he can hear you for the first time
and and give your marriage a shot
because this is not going in the good
direction hon
um
and i'm sorry i'm sure sorry you're
dealing with it yeah that it honestly
makes me mad there is not a financial
technique in the world that will fix
this situation
no not one
uh andreas is with us in santa fe new
mexico hey andreas how are you i'm doing
well how are you better than i deserve
what's up
i was looking uh for some career advice
uh right now i'm a i'm a livestock
manager on a ranch
and i've come across an opportunity
to move uh to a different position on a
different outfit
it's a lesser paying job with lesser
titles
but a better culture
and i believe it would bring me a better
better home life is i have a
three-year-old boy and
i am i'm engaged to get married
[Music]
and i just wonder what your thoughts
were on that
uh
how much
less well right now i make thirty six
thousand and a salary and then i usually
get about nine thousand tips and bonuses
and this new job
would pay twenty eight thousand eight
hundred dollars in salary
but they offer a 10 match on the 401k
and
health insurance for the whole family
okay and what is the thing that's better
for your three-year-old the health
insurance
no right now uh my fiance she travels
back and forth two and a half hours
every week uh so she spends
three days uh two and a half hours away
so you wouldn't be separated from your
family
correct okay all right that's a good
start and you get married and she makes
what
um she makes right around twenty
thousand
okay uh so you have a forty six thousand
forty eight thousand dollar household
income
and um
i i think that's a good step one
i would take it
but i wouldn't want you to be doing that
10 years from now
right
we need a path for growth
yes sir yes sir in your income and in
your career
yes sir yes sir maybe something
self-employed
yeah and even for your own sense of
dignity and pride of the fact that
you're making progress so you don't feel
like you've taken a step backwards and
you stayed there taking a step back
backwards so that you can take a step
forward so just don't don't don't look
at this is like this is we've arrived at
this this is a strategic move
because of the reasons you've outlined
but you're going to continue to work on
making more
looking figuring out what that what's
the wedding date andres
i'm sorry what's your wedding date
uh we don't have one yet you do now as
soon as you move
okay
marry this girl you had a baby with her
marry her start your life unless you
want to get your family all together
let's let's get everything right there
at home and then that sets you up for
both of you to succeed going into the
future
christy good hour good hour james and
kelly this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show did you know over 18
million people listen to the ramsay show
every week and a lot of those people
listen on one of our 600 plus radio
stations across the country
to find a station near you head to the
ramsay show.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host christy
wright is
my co-host today ramsey personality
number one best-selling author of the
book business boutique thank you for
joining us america we're glad you're
here the phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two
kristen starts off this hour in eugene
oregon hi kristen how are you
good dave how are you today better than
i deserve what's up great thank you for
taking my call i wanted to call my
husband passed away suddenly about eight
weeks ago oh my um
and so i am trying
uh he
died of coping complications oh my god
i'm so sorry how old was he
he was 58. oh my i'm so sorry
okay thank you um
he did most of the finances for our
family for me and him our children are
are 29 26 and 21 so they're grown and
out of the house um i was
i knew
uh we did the finances together we did a
budget every two weeks or every month
and then every time we got paid uh
divided the money up into envelopes and
and did that but we did have
a collection
um
account uh from 2009
because he was diagnosed with leukemia
back in 2005
um at the time we didn't have insurance
so all of his chemotherapy treatment
ended up being turned over to
collections because the
hospital would only carry balances for
six months and then turn people over to
collections
with that being said um
it was about we started at about 125 000
and now uh we are down to
i guess i am down to uh 29 500
and i was we were just about ready to
possibly uh make make an offer to them
and see if they would settle that out
with us and now that he's gone i'm
they're kind of pressuring me
um they have a lien on a house that we
have and i just was hoping to get your
opinion on
uh maybe trying to settle that out with
them i just need to
get that over my head um gone is this
one singular
bill yes it's one singular bill there's
twenty nine thousand five hundred
dollars from the old cancer treatments
back in the early two thousands
uh late two thousand yen and they
and they sued you and took a lean
against the house
yes they did
okay and what is it the hospital
yes
okay yes it was originally the hospital
now it's at a collection agency
uh well it's at a law firm now um
okay
because they've sued you it's gone past
collection agency collection agency may
have a law firm in-house but they're
um okay okay
and and so do you have money
i can
i
i have some life insurance that i could
use um
how much
um about a hundred thousand okay good
good i couldn't get a whole he never
could have a lot of life insurance what
what other what other debt do you have
i have a
a car loan that is about uh three
thousand dollars and i have a travel
trailer that's about
2 400
are you going to keep it
the travel trailer i am for now okay um
i'm just not ready to let it hold right
it has a lien on it what is it worth
it's worth about 425 000.
and is it paid off
uh we owe about 144 000 on it but that's
not the home you live in
no
we moved for his job and so we kept that
home um it's rented currently
it's rented yes okay
all right apparently i rent i don't own
a home that i live in okay
well you got a lot on your plate for a
really fresh
recent tragedy
um
and so what i always try to do is do as
few moves as i can
this close to the loss
because it's hard to think clear
this close to the loss
where is the other house
uh it's in southern oregon it's okay
it's not in the same town i live in
okay
all right so um
what i would do is call
uh the do you have a law firm that has
the lien
you have records of a law firm that did
the lawsuit
i'm
i'm probably i'll have to look back
through the records i would rather you
call the law firm than the collection
agency because the collection agency is
somebody who's been working there about
two weeks and they sit in a cubicle
and they have zero power and zero cents
in most cases
sometimes you can get somebody but it's
very rare so what i'm trying to do is
get to somebody that's allowed to make
decisions and if you can even get a good
paralegal at the law firm you got a
better chance than you do a collector in
a cube
so okay i'd get them on the phone
and say um
i'm willing to settle this for a lump
sum today
if you make me a deal what will you make
me
it should be 50 cents
okay 15 grand ought to settle this
they may start a little higher but no
matter what they say go oh my gosh
you're kidding i thought it'd be better
than that
okay act surprised about how horrible
their offer is no matter how good it is
okay okay because for them this is a
game for you this is your life
exactly
yeah and so mess with them kiddo
have you got enough stuff inside of you
right now with all this pain to do that
i think so i think it's just tough i
mean i've lost about three quarters of
my income you know losing my husband and
i'm trying to make it all work so what
i'm gonna do is is they you call up and
they say okay we'll take ten thousand
dollars go oh my gosh i so thought it
was gonna be better than that can you
not do any better
okay and just see what they say and when
they say seven say okay i guess
but if they say fifteen say the same
thing and just just just go at them a
couple times in one conversation now
in writing
they have to send you an email or a
certified letter or something in writing
saying they will accept that amount as
settlement in full and then you wire
money to them
no electronic access to your checking
account under any circumstances
and no deal until it's in writing if
it's not in writing it didn't happen
okay they
lie yeah
okay
so
if you have more than one conversation
and this starts to drain you hire an
attorney pay somebody a thousand dollars
to go do this for you
it'll be worth it okay
because you're not you may not have the
i'm not sure i'd have the shops and i do
this all the time
right and i'm not sure if sharon was
gone i'd have the chops to go fight it
eight weeks later okay so don't don't
let yourself get
pinned in the corner because of the
situation you're in emotionally but take
one run at it and let me just tell you i
think a year from now that house is sold
and you're buying a house with the
equity from that and you're setting
yourself up in a whole different life
that's a lot more conservative
than the one you're in i do not want you
to keep that house long term but you
don't have to be an emergency to sell it
immediately
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices and they make it
simple to shop blinds shades and
interior shutters with easy online
ordering free shipping and a guaranteed
perfect fit go to blinds.com and take
advantage of this week's special savings
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
according to the united states census
bureau nearly 1 in 10 people relocated
last year and that was 2020 that means
this year there's a good chance you or
someone you know is planning a big move
now i know it feels like there's a
thousand unknowns that you're juggling
when you're relocating but you cannot
lose focus of one of the most important
personal and financial factors in your
move your housing
i recommend hiring a quality real estate
agent like one of our endorsed local
providers or elps to help you find the
right home in your new city elps are top
performing experts in their local market
and have years of experience helping
folks just like you make successful
moves it's easy to get instantly
connected with an endorsed local
provider agent just go to
ramseysolutions.com
agent to talk with a ramsey trusted
agent about how they can help you with
your relocation ramsay solutions.com
slash agent they're ramsey trusted
blinds.com is our question of the day
they have a 100 satisfaction guarantee
means even if you mismeasure you pick
the wrong color they'll remake your
window blinds for free you get free
samples free shipping and with the new
promos they run every month you'll save
even more use the promo code ramsey to
get the best deal
today's question comes from jackson in
utah
i'm currently working in sales for a
software company but i want to start my
own software business i'm debt free
other than my mortgage 245 thousand
dollars should i pay off my house before
starting my own company or go for it
once i have enough cash to build the
product and start selling it
you just cash flow and you can do that
now you know baby steps
baby step six is number six for a reason
uh you know and dave i work with a lot
of people that start businesses that
don't need a lot of upfront costs but if
you can
cash flow that you can do that now
unless i'm missing something i think you
start your own software business if you
can
start it on the side
uh while working for the current company
without any ethical problems or
conflicts with customers or anything
like that um
then i would i would get it going and
get enough get the product built and uh
you can start selling it on the side you
don't have to just quit your job to go
do that as a matter of fact i wouldn't
right yeah and i would say especially
with something like software start out
with your 1.0 version this doesn't have
to be the cadillac version where you
save up a ton of money prove your idea
and your concept start it on the side
with the 1.0 version you can improve and
iterate over time and that will help you
get it to market faster and get feedback
faster yeah absolutely and you'll
because you're going to iterate anyway
whatever you put out there is going to
change you can count on it
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five josh is in
appleton wisconsin hey josh how are you
i'm doing fabulous sir how about
yourself better than i deserve how can
christy and i help
first of all thank you for taking my
call both of you sure
um my question is about my 18 year old
son just graduated
he's
gone through a youth friendship program
and showing up for work every day all
that good stuff
the company he's
working for
offered a
contract to reimburse
for
uh technical college in a trade in
machining
but but there's not
and he's required
to work for three years otherwise
if he quits within that three years says
this isn't for me or whatever
he has to reimburse
them
so my question is he loves working for
him
they've treated him very well
um i like the company we met with the
owner a couple nights ago and
they're
everything looks right
but there isn't a dollar amount to when
you're done with the apprenticeship
program
this is what you're gonna make he told
us this is what he's gonna make
and said i guarantee it and he said it
twice
what direction do i go with sorry what
was the
i thought you said you didn't know so
you do know what he's gonna make
in a handshake
basically okay but not on paper it's not
in the paperwork okay it's not in the
comments ask them to put it in the offer
letter
okay
when we hire someone here we give them
an offer letter
that states their start date what
they're going to make what their
benefits are
so they know what they're signing up for
and it's us putting it in writing so
they know what they're getting when they
come to work here 16 new people came to
work here on monday all of them did so
several weeks after receiving their
offer letter
and uh so sounds like this guy is a uh
a former machinist himself that runs a
small business
yes it's a smaller company yeah
he's just not he's not
super he's not super sophisticated in
his hr that's all
he's probably a great guy
and uh so what i would do is just say uh
since he's gonna owe you the money back
on this handshake
you're going to want to put that in
writing in the form of a letter so just
send him a letter saying how much he'll
make after the apprenticeship what you
told us in the meeting and go ahead and
put in the letter that if he doesn't
work three years that he's going to have
to reimburse the technical college and
of course you're going to look at your
costs on the technical college and your
son's going to know he's on the hook for
that
right and
he could cash flow right now
on his own he's been working and saving
everything well and so he could write a
check if he had to quit or got fired or
something
right but he really likes the place and
what i'm just saying how's your son
going to get pinched on this one would
be if he didn't get what was promised on
the income or two would be if there's
some kind of sideways thing on the
reimbursement on the college and so all
you gotta do is just put that both those
things in a letter to your son
from the owner
and you then you know you've got
something you can bring back it's
probably not a binding contract
that's not what i'm asking for
if i'm you uh but it's it's a point of
clarification and it's in writing in
case people forget
i got to tell you i put stuff down in
letters all the time two people what
i've promised them so that i have a copy
of it so i can remember what i said
because i got a couple deals in the air
yeah right and it looks like he's gonna
keep growing that the business looks
really strong yeah you'd go with this i
mean you see hearing red flags christy
no yeah it's just it's a matter of just
clarifying it's just a good old boy
running a business and he he thought the
handshake was clear and you're like yeah
it is clear let's also put it on paper
so we can remember it that's all it is
it's just an extra step for you to feel
good about it you're stuck you know
listen just say listen it's not an act
of disrespect would you mind uh just for
our sake for our peace of mind giving
him an offer letter of what you're
offering him in income and in tuition
reimbursement and what his
responsibility is and you can kind of
wink at the old guy and go and so this
is also for him to remember he owes you
that money if he leaves i want him to i
want him to understand he's getting on
the hook here
and this is you like telling you telling
him to how to coach your son up you know
kind of thing
yep yeah and that's why that way it's
not offensive to him right you're just
saying hey put it in an offer letter
that way i can make this 18 year old
knucklehead stay on track i'll help you
with him and
you know and uh uh then we all know what
we said and it's real easy and it's not
that we're questioning your word at all
yeah so and he'll he'll do that just
it's a simple letter have you have your
assistant write out a quick letter and
send it to us uh just send him an offer
letter just call it an offer letter
because that's really what it is yeah in
hr terms
and uh but it's it's you're wise to
clarify it and get it in writing mainly
because people get busy and they forget
most people aren't dishonest but
sometimes they get busy and they forget
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five uh christy is
talking these days and did at entree
leadership in depth about balance
in our lives about spending our time as
carefully as we spend our money
and christy and her team have developed
the
24 hour challenge they want to give you
24 hours of your week back
by using their new free
time finder
if you want to get the free time finder
to check on your
time like we check on your money
text time finder to 33
444. text time finder to 33
4 44.
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage drew and erica are with
us hey guys how are you hey we're doing
good welcome and where do you guys live
uh we're in hebron idaho oh wow did you
drive or fly to tennessee we flew good
i feel better about you already yes
that's a long way
okay cool man so how much debt did you
guys pay off uh we paid off 400 000
whoa nice and how long did this take
just over four years wow and your range
of income during that time 140 to 160.
oh okay did you sell something or
no no
we just you scrambled you just been on
beans and rice and put 100 grand a year
on this yes what kind of debt was it
it was 40 000 a personal and it was
about 360 000 of business debt oh wow
okay so now your business is paid for
paid for
and uh and and sure is a little bit more
profit after that
yeah we're actually able to keep
something so that's nice what a concept
yeah we've made a lot of money and we've
lived on yeah 50 grand so yeah what kind
of business it's cnc machine shop oh
good good cool and what do you do erica
i'm a stay-at-home mom but i recently
finished your financial coach master
training program and so i'm in the
process of building my financial
coaching business good
wow look at you guys cool very fun well
congratulations so tell us about your
journey what happened four years ago
that put you on this process well it
actually started about 10 years ago drew
was working at a different machine shop
and he had an idea of how to
build some parts better than they were
doing so he approached the boss and
and
contracted the workout so we bought a
machine and put it in our garage but we
had to borrow money from a family member
to do that and the payment was really
big almost as big as our mortgage and we
got kind of worried that we weren't
going to be able to make the payment so
we started putting our living expenses
on credit cards
and
we paid the machine off on time and
never missed a payment but we got into
some really bad habits of just living in
excess of our of what we made every year
i guess
and so um
drew was kind of frustrated with me i
was bouncing checks and the credit card
companies kept calling me asking why
aren't you making your payments you know
and i just i could only pay what i could
so
uh he decided that he was going to take
over the finances
and he didn't do any better than i did
he was busy and
i didn't realize how frustrating it was
um after that
we had the genius idea to do a debt
consolidation loan and um only one bank
we went to several banks and one bank
said yes to us and we walked out of
there with the loan and said oh we're
never going to do that again and about
two or three months later we'd racked up
24 000 more of credit
yeah so um
we were kind of disasters
so
you found oh yeah so um
when the frustration got bad enough and
we realized what we've done i had this
random memory from about 25 years ago i
remember riding in a br in a car with my
brother and my dad
my brother was telling my dad about this
guy that he'd heard on the radio that
basically
was teaching about money and said
something to the effect of you've got to
deliver pizzas until you save six months
worth of income
that's all i can remember
but i did remember your name and so when
i went to google i found the radio state
or the radio show
the podcast and started listening
every day wow yeah and then he told me
about it and i was
i told him i said oh i'm totally on
board with getting out of debt i want to
start investing but everybody has a car
payment and everybody has a house
payment so i'll do the other stuff but
i'm not doing the car payment and house
payment and he was really patient with
me he just said okay okay
and um at the time i really really
wanted a yukon
and so i thought if we just pay off the
debt then i can go get a payment for a
yukon and i and he just kept saying okay
that's fine but um for our anniversary
he had bought tickets to celine dion in
vegas
it's about a 10-hour car ride from where
we live and i didn't realize this at the
time but he had planned to trap me in
the car and make me listen to the total
funny makeover
for ten hours well played drew yeah
thank you well played but once again
celine dion is the baby
dave is the tiger i'm gonna lure you in
with this chick concert and then teach
you about money on the way exactly but
not too long into it celine would
appreciate this
yeah not too far into the trip i
realized that that
following the plan completely is what we
needed to do and
as soon as you said the line in the book
um what is it if you if you paid
yourself a car payment for 30 years
you'd have 5 million hope you liked your
car wow yeah she stopped and turned and
said oh crap i don't get a uk
so what you're saying is
so what you're saying is yeah
after that we were pretty much on board
we were just
gazelle intense yeah
for four years yeah wow wow yes that's
impressive y'all very good and so
basically what ended up happening was
you rolled all this consumer debt over
into the business almost all of it well
i 360 000 on business you said yeah yeah
what happened is i was i had rented some
machine time and subconscious
some contracted some work through a
business and that guy actually passed
away
so i i had to scramble to
get some machines and
kind of build a little shop in the
backyard
so i either was going to close the
business and get a job or do what i did
so i doubled down yeah
wow way to go guys thank you just a lot
of work huh yeah that's all it was
you're working a bazillion hours a week
yeah just take all you can get and plow
through and then you're done was it
worth it oh yeah 100 because you're done
now yeah you got to feel like you got to
feel like you lost 300 pounds
we've listened to a lot of debt free
screams and uh
nothing that anyone can say
relays the feeling of freedom
wow
yeah drew drew works like i don't know
16 18-hour days he he uh started
sleeping in the shop and he'd take my
couch cushions and lay on the shop floor
with them and finally i bought him a cot
i said at least if you're going to do
this give me back my couch cushions and
be comfortable
i want you to be comfortable a little
mostly i want my couch back yeah but he
puts in a lot of hours and so wow
and she's kind of been a single mother
yeah she took care of everything else
i just started googling how to do stuff
because i just he didn't have the time
to do stuff so something would happen
and i thought well i don't know how to
do it so youtube or google and just make
it happen
yeah yeah now you're free though yeah
i'm so proud of y'all yeah you're an
incredible couple you guys are heroes
you took control of your life well done
very well done and you work like maniacs
i mean and you work like no one else
later you get to work like no one else
now you can do whatever you want to do i
mean that's right you can play this
however you want to play it and you
brought the guys with you they got three
sons right and their names and ages uh
this is brooks he's 12. jace is nine and
dax is six
awesome very cool good-looking guys yes
we've got a copy of the legacy journey
for you that's definitely uh something
you've done for those three young men
you've changed their legacy you're
leaving a legacy very well done and a
copy of the total money makeover and as
a coach you can give that to somebody or
a friend or whoever and pay it forward
and wake somebody up somebody uh give
somebody the hint that uh you use celine
dion
it's a trap date trap them in the car
with dave for 10 hours
oh my gosh that's just great that's a
new one that's the first unusual
punishment that's what i'm saying uh all
right drew erica brooks jason dax 400
000 paid off in four years
making 140 to 160. count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream
three two one
[Applause]
i love it
well done
i tell you what when you work 16 18 hour
days for three years
it is emotional you see it in his face i
wish people you know that that are just
listening could see it it's like oh you
feel that in your heart the freedom that
they feel yeah you you see the release
yes yeah it's uh man and and the other
thing about that situation is once you
paid that kind of price to get out
you'll never go that's right that's
right never go back no no not even close
not for any reason there's something
about
uh something that's that hard yeah that
it brands in your spirit yeah and it's
like no it's this visceral response to
it yeah the idea of getting a car
payment is enough to make you throw up
when you've acted like that yeah or
other people like well maybe someday i
might you know yeah
you know but
they'll never go back you don't even
need to ask them the question will you
ever go back no you know that's it and
not a chance i don't no no i want you
free right now once you pay a price like
that to get free
well done you guys very well done this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day psalm 37 3 and
4 trust in the lord and do good dwell in
the land and enjoy safe pasture take
delight in the lord and he will give you
the desires of your heart
jim rhodes jim rohn said you cannot
change your destination overnight
but you can change your direction
overnight kyle is with us in santa rosa
california hey kyle how are you
mr ramsey it's an honor to talk to you
sir you too sir what's up uh okay so
quick question i'm a i am a big listener
a friend of mine who is also a listener
uh recommended something to me i wanted
to run it by you
um i have a pickup truck that is
the 2006
uh
duramax diesel
he is suggesting
with the high market value of used cars
right now to sell it to put it towards
and potentially pay off my debt
what's the truck worth
uh blue book value has had it at about
14.
how much debt do you have
20 grand
how old are you
i'm 34
or i'll be 34 next week what do you make
uh with my with my wife and i we we
grossed about 145 last year
is this your daily driver truck or is it
a third vehicle or extra vehicle
uh well my wife has a car with our
family car with a new baby that we just
had and then i have my truck
okay so i would i would end up selling
it to get get a hooky as you like to
call it yeah uh to be my driver yeah do
you like the truck
i do like the truck
um
you know and that's what my buddy was
saying is that he was saying to
you know
get rid of the truck it's just a truck
put it toward your debt work towards
your house well if it was 40 if it was
44 000 maybe but it's only a 14 000
truck it's not
it doesn't fix the problem and it's not
that big a percentage of 145 000 if you
like it i would keep it and get your get
your butt on a budget and get this 20
grand in debt paid off and keep your
truck it's just a faster way for you to
jump start your debt paying off but you
can on that income you can do this
without selling it i would not sell it
instead i would roll up my sleeves and
get my household on a tight budget
everybody in the house and let's get
this twenty thousand dollars paid off i
don't know you make a hundred and forty
five let's
uh
let's do it in five months
okay four thousand dollars four thousand
dollars a month you can do that on that
income and you get to keep your truck
it's a little it's a little bit slower
than you doing it next week yeah well if
you sell the truck you're still gonna be
you still got six thousand dollars in
that's still going to take you two more
months yeah
yeah so the difference is a hooptie for
for saving you three months it's not and
then i wouldn't do anything i tried to
move back up out of hoopty into a better
car yeah
right
and and so that was just
the only reason i was thinking about it
is because of the like i said the uh
the demand for used vehicles today yeah
but so what i mean again if it was a 54
000 truck i'd sell it in a heartbeat on
you
sure but it's just it's not it's not
that big a percentage of the problem or
of your
income
so it doesn't move the needle enough for
the hassle
is my point got it
got it if you hate the truck anyway then
yeah let's dump it while the market's
high and get you something else but
that's not the problem you don't owe 14
on it right
no i don't know anything on it yeah
you're only debt is 20 000 other than
your home
uh yeah i don't we don't own our home so
we don't even have that okay
all right hey uh hold on i'm gonna have
kelly sign you guys up for a year in
ramsey plus and put you into financial
peace university
and get you on to every dollar premium
budgeting app and so we're going to show
you how to budget and how to handle your
money and how to work your way through
this debt and you're going to be able to
see after you go through financial peace
university with your wife uh you guys
are going to be able to see if you'll
dial into this i'll give it to you for
you for a year if you'll dial into it
but you got to go do it and then you got
to call me back and tell me you're debt
free but um you're going to be able to
see what christie and i are seeing
because we've looked at this for
years decades
and so we can see instantly that yeah
you need to just pay off this debt but
if you're gonna screw around and take
four years to get out of debt or
something with twenty thousand dollars
then you got other problems that are not
truck that the truck doesn't solve yeah
and especially on that income like this
is very doable on that income if you're
calling in with a thirty thousand dollar
income that's different but you can do
this
john's in boston hey john how are you
hi james i'm great how are you better
than i deserve how can we help
great uh well thanks for taking my call
um i've been listening for years and
you're actually one of the reasons i
wanted to become a finance major in
college so um thanks for the inspiration
i really appreciate it honored thank you
mike
thank you my question is what does
opportunity look like um i just
graduated college i
worked very hard to graduate debt free
and with a good chunk of change in the
banks and um
while i'm looking for a job i'm also
looking for opportunity
i think the economy is closing a great
position right now
intuition is it being extremely
organized is it networking like how do
you just put all the pieces together and
make stuff happen
what is it you're looking for
well i guess i'm looking for um
something to focus all my all my passion
and energy towards whether it be a
a job or an opportunity to start my own
thing i'm just what do you want to do
too short i mean when you when you just
think about that really simple question
what do you want to do what do you see
yourself doing um i
i love helping people with their
finances
i love learning about financial literacy
and um
and personal finance and
so that's definitely one of my big
passions i also really like real estate
but i'm
i'm not too sure exactly what
oh and you're you just graduated in your
senior year i'm sure in classes you
talked about all the different ways to
use that degree were there any that
jumped out to you more than others
there's a lot of ways to use that degree
um yeah that's true well um
i guess there were a lot more things
that jumped out at me that i knew i
didn't want to do than
things that i actually did want to do
studying finance was more of
institutional and corporate finance and
i
not sure if i particularly like that
side of finance i'm more of a
people person and like
talking with people and building
relationships and things like that
so i guess um
just some wisdom or guidance into how to
kind of enter that realm of finance and
enter that world why don't you uh click
on smart vester at
ramseysolutions.com and see if you can
find a smartvestor pro or two in the
area to talk to you
about the possibility of being a
financial advisor working on one of
their teams and what it would take to
get to be that and do that what what
kind of um
ramp up there would be what kind of uh
on-ramp there would be to do that uh
because it sounds like you're wanting to
get hand-to-hand kneecapped an e-cap
with folks and actually help them with
their investments or help them with
their money in some way
and that might be a a way to start
doing that the other thing i would tell
you to do is just uh comb through the
different free offerings on
kencoleman.com
ken coleman's website
he's got a lot of stuff on there about
getting how you get clear on what it is
you're wanting to do
um and then what your next steps are
and we'll send you a copy of his book
the proximity principle
i was the number one bestseller about
about the importance of being in
proximity to the people the places
the activities that you want to be a
part of you you still are pretty
panned back this is still very big
picture
um and so your next step is to get more
clarity on
exactly which direction to move yeah and
you'll learn some of that through doing
your first job out of college won't be
your dream job that's okay it's just do
something in the direction you want to
go get your feet wet get some reps real
life experience and go oh i really like
this but not so much this it's going to
teach you about yourself and more about
what you want by doing something so so
look look get clarity and then take some
action ken's resources will help you do
that
and that's good wisdom i never really
thought about it until you said that but
my first job out of college was not my
dream job it was my nightmare job
it was the worst in the world
worse the worst people too it was just
nasty
ugh
christy wright good job james childs
kelly daniels in the booth good job i'm
dave ramsey your host we'll be back with
you before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
you